muslims in norway are now establishing a
masjid and dawa center to enhance the
norwegian tawa if you donate to the
schools you will insha allah reap the
rewards of thousands of muslims coming
back to islam and many of those who
become dwight and invite to islam so
click the link and donate now and share
the video for extra rewards
with allah how are you guys doing and
welcome um
on behalf
of islam net in fact who which is a
norwegian organization organization
which aims to create bridges between
muslim and non-muslim communities
they're doing some great work we are
joined with an esteemed
uh legendary you know professor
professor bar ehrman many of you already
know who he is but if you don't know i'm
going to quickly tell you
um has written or edited 33 books
including six new new york times
bestsellers how jesus became god
misquoting jesus
um god's problem jesus interrupted
forged and the triumph
of christianity bart is uh james a grey
distinguished professor of religious
studies at the university of north
carolina carolina chapel hill where he
has taught thousands of students and won
numerous awards
um you know bart's work has been
featured in the new york times
washington post uh the new uh newsweek
has appeared on national geographic cnn
bbc nbc uh dateline and many other
places as well um how are you uh today
professor yep i'm i'm doing well thanks
doing well
i i think many people will know who you
are especially from um kind of our
follower base because of your kind of
work and how it's had an impact
on kind of apologetics whether it's
christian apologetics uh islamic
apologetics or otherwise even new
atheists reference your work and so it's
really um a pleasure to have you on i
think the first question i'd like to ask
you um regarding your line of specialism
is
about the reliability of the new
testament okay um
first and foremost you you came to a
conclusion in your own life in your own
kind of development
that the new testament is not reliable
why did you come to that conclusion
yeah you know and part i did come to
that conclusion i started out as a as a
very conservative fundamentalist
christian who uh believed that every
word in the bible was completely true
and that there were no errors of any
kind
scientific geographical historical
anything
and over time i came to realize that uh
that that wasn't right and in part it
was because i recognized i finally i was
i was open to any point of view i came i
came to recognize that in fact there are
discrepancies and uh and contradictions
in the new testament just say between
the gospels uh and their accounts of
jesus or between what the book of acts
says about paul what paul says about
paul or about so they're they're
discrepancies and obviously if they're
discrepancies they both both views
stated can't can't be true so the the
trick is though what does it mean to be
unreliable
i mean if you've got a
you know if you've got a friend who uh
who's giving you directions and about
ten percent of the time they're wrong
you know you don't know if you can trust
him or not but it's not that he's like
completely unreliable it's just you have
to figure out once he when's he got it
right and not and that's how it is with
that's how it is with the new testament
especially you've got to figure out
where it's right and and where there are
mistakes
and how how can one figure that out in
in layman's terms like if if now many
christians may be watching this and say
well they object to this fact and they
believe that every word and every
sentence
of the bible is in fact inspired by god
and that they're they believe in
biblical inerrancy they don't believe
that there's any such thing as an error
in the bible they'll be
very much taken aback by what you're
saying and say we find it objectionable
in fact so what would you do in order to
prove to them that this is not the case
well you know that as i said that's how
i started out too i when i graduated
from high school i went to uh moody
bible institute in chicago which is a
it's a bastion of fundamentalism and i
was completely i was completely sold for
years so this is absolutely there is not
a word wrong in the bible um it was
finally when i started i learned greek
so i could read the new testament in
greek and i learned hebrews i could read
the old testament in hebrew and i
started and i started really studying
these texts very closely and i started
finding that there are uh you know there
there are discrepancies i mean mark will
say one thing and matthew will say
something else and it's the opposite
thing you don't know this unless you
really look closely but when you do that
then you see this and so so yeah how do
you go about finding out what's right
well you do it the way any historian
finds out what happened in the past i
mean if you're talking about uh you know
uh abraham lincoln or the emperor
constantine or whatever churchill you
you you have to historians look at all
the evidence they consider who's writing
it they consider how close it is to the
source they consider how many sources
they have they see if they're consistent
with each other they they uh you know
they they try to work out what what most
plausibly happened and that's all you
can do with the new testament too you
treat it like a historical source if you
want to know what happened historically
i mean uh just a bit of my background
that at one point when i was um actually
auditing a course at the university of
oxford
doing um on text criticism it's not
something i actually specialize in
myself but i did audit a text criticism
course as part of my
um applied
applied
theology masters and i knew for a fact
that i was well over my kind of people
were on a different level i mean you
have to have
like you said language skills and i said
this is a specialism in and of itself
you need to have language skills there
are you know polygons people have many
different languages under their belt
like you said hebrew and and greek and
sometimes other languages as well
and so i do really respect the level of
work that comes into you know your line
of specialism
someone has to learn this language and
then manuscript
uh kind of analysis and and looking at
trying to draw inferences from it and
stuff like this is it really is the work
of such and you've been doing this for
that many years so obviously
um it was only then really when i
started to realize how heavy this was in
terms of
being able to be a great
text critic it's not something that
someone could just do in a year or two
it's something that one must actually
dedicate a considerable chunk of their
life but i'm wondering why you decided
to do so because when i was looking at
some of
the videos about your story you left
christianity because of this reason from
what i understand but what kept you
interested in this topic
so um what i so i got i got interest i
got interested in text criticism so some
people may not know exactly what that
means it doesn't really just mean
interpretation of text as you said it
has to do with manuscripts you with the
new testament uh we have thousands of
manuscripts but they have many many
differences between them and so since we
don't have the originals we have to look
at these manuscripts to find out what
the what the authors originally wrote
and so text criticism is not deciding
whether what the authors wrote was true
or not it's just finding out what did
they actually write and it's not just
the new testaments every book from
antiquity is like this so every every
you know shakespeare is like this or a
cl i'm chaucer i mean everybody all
these books you've got to figure out the
author wrote so i got interested in that
because i i believed that the original
words were inspired by god and so i
wanted to know what the words were since
we have all these manuscripts that have
differences in them so that's what got
me going what kept me going is um was
somewhat different i actually did leave
the faith about 25 years ago i stopped
being a christian and it wasn't actually
because of the scholarship it turned the
reason i left the faith was um was not
because i knew the bible had mistakes or
i knew that for a long time and i stayed
a christian for a long time knowing that
what that made me leave the faith was
being i got to a point where i just
couldn't believe that there was a god
who is in the world who is active a
loving powerful god who's active in the
world
given all of the massive suffering that
people experience i just thought you
know i just don't believe it anymore but
then why do i continue being a new
testament scholar i'm passionate about
the new testament i'm passionate about
the study of early christianity and
largely it's because it is such an
important historical phenomenon and
christianity took over the entire roman
empire and became the religion of the
western world basically i mean the
dominant religion of the western world
and there's still more christians in the
world than anything else it's like whoa
it's really important and the new
testament is at the very root of it's
the foundation of it and so it's
important for me to understand what the
foundation is
and to try and teach other people what
the foundation is because most people
really don't know uh and so that's why
well i mean your work as as i've said
it's not just applicable or relevant to
kind of christians it's very much
relevant to muslims as well because as
you know in the islamic faith muslims
believe in jesus christ as well and
obviously there's competing narrative
ideas as to who jesus christ was in fact
and
um the main i would say the fundamental
difference between the kind of muslim
faith in the christian faith in this
regard
is that
muslims view jesus christ as a prophet
and a mess as a messenger prophet and
the messiah but not as god or the son of
god in fact they
you know the quran is very explicit that
he doesn't
um he doesn't claim to be a he doesn't
claim to be a god himself in fact this
is seen as a fabricated or some kind of
a contrivance
on the on the narrative and really the
the islamic idea is that there cannot be
someone it's not intelligible or
conceivable or pardonable uh for someone
with a date of birth to be referred to
as god anyway so
jesus christ will be disqualified from
from that perspective but this is why
there's there's a lot of interest i
think from the muslim community
on
um
on your kind of work because this is
historical work that's being done and
many muslims feel that kind of your
vision of or your conclusions your
historical conclusions of who jesus
christ is is more commensurate with at
least the muslim idea than it is with
the christian one to what extent would
you agree or disagree with that notion
you